die queen sie war irgendwie immer da
staatschefs und regierungschefinnen auf
der ganzen welt bekunden ihr beileid
auch deutschlands bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier
mit tiefer trauer habe ich die nachricht
vom tod ihrer majestät königin
elizabeth der zweite
vernommen
königin elizabeth war eine frau die ein
jahrhundert geprägt hat im vereinigten
königreich
und darüber hinaus weltweit sie hat zeit
geschichte erlebt und
zeitgeschichte geschrieben
ihre majestät genoss auf der ganzen welt
höchstes ansehen und respekt
bei uns hier in deutschland wurde sie
bewundert und verehrt millionen deutsche
fühlen sich heute in trauer und
herzliche anteilnahme
mit den menschen im vereinigten
königreich
verbunden
ihre
natürliche autorität
ihre immense erfahrung ihre vorbildliche
pflichterfüllung werden uns in
lebendiger erinnerung bleiben
ihr tod ist ein tiefer einschnitt
das ende einer epoche die
vergangenen sieben jahrzehnte hat
königin elizabeth die zweite als
regentin gewirkt und die politik des
vereinigten königreichs in guten wie in
schweren tagen begleitet erst im juni
dieses jahres
hat sie ihr platin jubiläum begangen
unter der großen und freudigen
anteilnahme ihres landes und millionen
menschen weltweit auch in deutschland
ihre majestät die geschicke ihres landes
behutsam und doch allenthalben spürbar
mitbestimmt sein ansehen gemehrt ihm mit
selbstloser disziplin ein leben lang
gedient
sie hat die
einheit des landes repräsentiert
und verkörperte kontinuität und
gewissheit in zeiten in denen das
vereinigte königreich
gewaltige veränderungen durchlebt
mein mitgefühl und das der deutschen
bevölkerung gilt auch besonders ihre
familie ich wünsche ihnen könig charles
in diesen tagen kraft gottes segen und
eine glückliche hand für die große
aufgabe
die jetzt auf sie übergegangen ist
und wir gehen direkt vor die britische
botschaft in berlin meine kollegin
antonia jamin dort vor ort antonia
schönen guten morgen ihr die trauer ist
groß nicht nur jene hauptstadt auf der
ganzen welt
ja genau also hier bei der britische
botschaft trautmann natürlich um die
queen man kann vielleicht hier hinter
mir sehen in der nacht hat man hier
blumen und kerzen hinterlegt es ist sehr
bewegend und ein mensch hat sogar ein
gin tonic hingestellt ich weiß nicht
wenn du weißt aber die queen hat vor ein
paar jahren hier eigenen job angefangen
zu produzieren von blumen also von ihrem
schloss
jemand dachte halt es das irgendwie nett
wäre wahrscheinlich
und man sieht auch hier natürlich wie
die flagge auf halbmast
gesunken wurden es aber das ist
natürlich nicht nur hier in der
hauptstadt in der britischen botschaft
es ist auf der ganzen welt auf dem
ganzen welt auf der ganze welt sieht man
heute wie flaggen halbmast gesetzt
worden sind es gibt gebäude überall auf
die welt die eliminiert worden sind mit
der britischen
farben in jordanien ein land das
irgendwie mich wirklich was großes jetzt
mit der queen zu tun hat hat man sieben
tage trauer tage angekündigt in
brasilien drei
trauertagen am endeffekt sehr man über
die queen gesprochen hat wenn man gesagt
hat die queen hat man nicht irgend eine
königin auf diese welt gemein man hat
immer queen elizabeth die zweite gemeint
und gestern ich sie von uns weg jetzt
erwachte die hauptstadt hier heute alles
ist noch dunkel weil die ja aber gestern
wenige momente nach dem bekanntwerden
des todes der queen versammelten sich
dort in diesem ort wurde jetzt stehst
dann turnier natürlich viele menschen in
trauer wir haben mit ihnen gesprochen
lasst uns einmal gemeinsam reinhören
über den schock und totaler schock also
wir konnten uns alle gar nicht glauben
wir sind sofort hierher gefahren sie war
irgendwie immer meinem leben also ich
weiss nicht
fand es besonders dass sie ihr ganzes
leben war besonders
die wird schon immer lieber tom also
was genau die gab es schon immer das
spricht eben für die große
fassungslosigkeit dass so eine konstante
plötzlich weg ist antonia mit ihrem ihn
vor der britischen botschaft das
bedeutet der tod der queen für
großbritannien aber auch für die welt
also die queen war ja immer ein symbol
auch für stabilität und
sie es jetzt halt weg und die welt ist
und stabiler geworden wir haben wieder
krieg in europa leute wissen nicht mal
wenn sie im winter ihre wohnungen heizen
konnten und in großbritannien haben wir
seit drei tage eine neue
premierministerin
dass kein mandat wirklich vom volk hat
sie wurde nicht vom volk gewählt das
heißt dass wir wahrscheinlich in den
nächsten kommenden monate wieder
neuwahlen in großbritannien sehen es
gibt es kein großer
staatsführer darin in großbritannien es
wird jetzt halt charles sein der neue
könig und nur das zu sagen ist schon
irgendwie komisch weil in den letzten 70
jahren gab es halt nur die eine green
das hat man halt immer gemeint und ich
werde vielleicht noch ich erinnere mich
noch so klar an die rede dass sie damals
bei corona gehalten hat es war april
2020 die hat diese berühmte rede
gehalten die live 24 millionen menschen
auf der ganzen welt nicht nur in
großbritannien gesehen haben die hat
damals gesagt womit auf sein so gern
höhere mieten
vermieten also wir werden unsere familie
sehen uns unsere freunde sind und wir
werden uns wiedertreffen
sie hatte natürlich recht weil sie schon
so viel erlebt hat aber jetzt gestern
ist sie gestorben
antonia die arminia vor der britischen
botschaft hier in berlin vielen
herzlichen dank dir für deine
informationen an diesem morgen
die welt ist in anteilnahme am tod der
queen und so auch us präsident joe biden
erstattete der britischen botschaft in
den usa einen besuch ab um das
kondolenzbuch zu ehren der verstorbenen
queen zu unterschreiben und kurze zeit
später fand er folgende worte
ich möchte ein paar worte über die queen
sagen ich habe gerade bei der britischen
botschaft vorbeigeschaut um ihr zu ehren
das kondolenzbuch zu unterschreiben ich
hatte die gelegenheit sie zu treffen
bevor sie starb und sie war eine
unglaublich liebenswürdige und
anständige frau die gedanken und gebete
des amerikanischen volkes sind bei den
menschen im vereinigten königreich und
im commonwealth
die ganze welt es sind trauer und hält
kurz den atem an auch bundeskanzler olaf
scholz äußerte sich bei twitter schauen
wir rein was der kanzler zum tod der
queen geschrieben hat er hatte auch
diesen tweet abgesetzt gestern abend
noch nach dem bekanntwerden des todes
die welt in schock und der kanzler
schreibt wir trauern um queen elizabeth
die zweite sie war vorbild und
inspiration für millionen auch hier in
deutschland
ihr einsatz für die deutsch britische
aussöhnung nach den schrecken des
zweiten weltkrieges bleibt unvergessen
sie wird fehlen nicht zuletzt ihr
wundervoller humor das schreibt also der
kanzler das ist nicht die einzige
reaktion auf der welt nicht nur politik
auch showbiz trauert mit jagger
berühmter frontmann von den rolling
stones etwa er schreibt dieses hier mein
ganzes leben lang war ihre majestät
königin elizabeth ii die zweite immer da
ich kann mich erinnern dass ich in
meiner kindheit ihrer hochzeit
highlights im fernsehen gesehen habe ich
erinnere mich an sie es eine
wunderschöne junge dame die viel
geliebte großmutter der nation mein
tiefstes mitgefühl gilt der königlichen
familie schauen wir direkt nach london
schauen wir in die hauptstadt julia
willi schewski dort vor ort an diesem
morgen an dem die welt sollen wir es
gesagt
kleines bisschen still steht und auch
wenn man dort in großbritannien jetzt
erst erwacht so erwartet man mit
sicherheit auch in großer trauer
absolut hier herrscht wirklich einiges
gespenstische atmosphäre ist fast schon
unheimlich ist es her noch sehr früh am
morgen und dennoch sind bereits menschen
hier zu buckingham palace gekommen es
brennen kerzen zahlreiche blumen und
kränze wurden niedergelegt und das zeigt
eben auch ja wie sehr die queen mit
ihren engländern sozusagen verbunden war
weil es eben ja hier tatsächlich noch so
früh ist die ganze nacht aber leute
hierher kam und es ist ja fast schon wie
gesagt gespenstisch es ist sehr dunkel
das wetter hat sich geändert gestern war
ja dieser doppel regenbogen zu sehen als
equine lese bürste jahr verstarb oder im
sterben lag und man merkt so richtig die
menschen suchen fast schon die symbolik
sie suchen auch so diese ja über
natürliche erklärungen fast und jedes
bisschen hoffnung und man hat richtig
gespürt wie alle an sie denken und in
ihren gedanken eben bei ihr sind in mit
diesem letzten stunden und das geht nun
auch weiter in den folgenden tagen wo
ganz england und natürlich die ganze
welt trauert um die queen
[Musik]